las alarmas sonaron a partir de las
cuatro de la mañana en toda Ucrania una
cena que ya se había convertido en común
en el país a partir de octubre cuando
Moscú comenzó esa campaña de ataques
simultáneos con misiles y drones
kamikasis de fabricación iraní no
solamente contra la infraestructura
eléctrica del país sino también contra
áreas civiles como sucedió esta
madrugada uno de esos misiles cayó en la
ciudad de Nitro en una residencia
familiar donde murió una madre con su
hijo de 2 años también solo volaron la
ciudad de kiev donde alcanzaron a ser
interceptados pero lo peor sucedió en la
ciudad de humana en el corazón de
Ucrania en el centro del país una ciudad
de 80.000 habitantes que hasta ahora se
había mantenido prácticamente aislada de
la guerra solamente había sido atacado
muy al comienzo de esta invasión a gran
escala este edificio que fue es de 9
pisos se dice que 100 personas residían
allí 46 apartamentos la mitad de ellos
quedaron destruidos Y a esta hora siguen
buscando personas bajo los escombros
este nuevo ataque que fue según las
autoridades lanzado por bombarderos
rusos desde las proximidades del mar
caspio vienen un momento el que se
espera que comience esa contraofensiva
de la que tanto ha hablado el gobierno
ucraniano hoy habló el ministro de
defensa ucraniano y dijo que todo estaba
listo para ella que cuando Dios quisiera
el clima lo permitiera y los comandantes
lo dijeran empezaría esta ofensiva a la
que también se refería ayer el
secretario general de la otan diciendo
que el 98% de las armas prometidas para
esta contraofensiva ya estaban en el
país